The trailer opens with this metronome, the
same device that psychic medium Elise Rainier
used to hypnotize Josh Lambert in the first
Insidious so that he could go into the Further
and rescue his son.
The reappearance of it here suggests that
he’ll be going back into The Further to
settle some unfinished business.
There’s also a shot of someone using a digital
metronome propped up on the side of a bed.
Dalton used to astral project in his sleep
before being hypnotized to forget about his
ability at the end of Insidious Chapter 2.
I cringe for this USB port, but I would guess
that this is Dalton, trying to rediscover
the mysteries of his past.
We’re shown flashes of the family’s past
in Insidious 1 and 2, before being taken forward
10 years, with Dalton set to head off to college.
To learn whose funeral the family is attending,
what happened to Josh over the years and what
might be hidden in each Insidious logo, stick
around to the end of this video.
♪ (metal intro) ♪
Welcome to Things You Missed, trailer edition.
Today I’m looking at the first trailer for
Insidious: The Red Door.
Since the trailer glosses through things pretty
quickly, I thought it would be a good idea
to go back through shot by shot and analyze
what we’re supposed to take away from the
trailer.
Insidious: The Red Door is the long awaited
follow up to the Lambert family story.
The last two movies were prequels, exploring
the past of Elise.
So we never got to see what happens after
ghost Elise discovered The Red Face demon
haunting a new family.
But we are definitely going to.
Let’s cut in to the Things You Missed.
♪ (ominous music) ♪
At the end of the second movie, Josh and Dalton
are hypnotized to erase their abilities to
astral project into The Further because of
the danger associated with it.
I’ve been saying for like 10 years now that
this was not a good idea, because Josh forgot
his ability when he was a kid, and this left
him very ill prepared when his son demonstrated
the ability years later.
They would have been better off learning to
harness their abilities like Elise.
Sure enough, another 10 years go by, meaning
that The Red Door is set in 2020.
It seems like a lot of movies just like to
exist in a universe where COVID never happened
for some reason.
It’s weird, because I can’t really think
of any movies set in 1940s Germany that don’t
acknowledge the Holocaust.
Maybe the pain from COVID is still too fresh
for screenwriters to want to think about it.
Josh is seen doing a memory exercise where
he flips over photos of his family members.
He seems to be in a new house, and it’s
good to see that they got a new armchair rather
than keeping that one that Elise died on.
It seems he’s beginning to see ghosts again,
and his nightmares have come back.
As a kid, he would astral project in his sleep,
which he perceived as a series of nightmares.
The shot where he wakes up is deliberately
framed so we don’t see the other side of
his bed, and in all the shots where he’s
at home, he’s alone, leading me to believe
that he and Renai may not be together anymore.
Add that to the fact that he’s got all these
photos of her around the house… it makes
it look like he misses her.
Renai also suggests he drive Dalton to college
to reconnect, which may suggest that they’ve
been apart.
When driving Dalton to college, he’s holding
something, possibly some kind of cigar, which
could also be a clue about his issues.
Maybe I’m totally over speculating, but
it’s possible that his memory issues are
connected to relationship issues with his
family.
The only time he and Renai are seen together
is at this funeral.
And speaking of which, who died?
The kids are grown up in this shot, so this
isn’t Elise’s funeral, it’s 10 years
later.
There are four characters who don’t appear
in the trailer: The paranormal investigators
Specs and Tucker, Elise’s ghost hunter colleague
Carl, and Josh’s mom: Lorraine.
I’m going to guess that they’re attending
Lorraine’s funeral, since they’re probably
not still in contact with Specs, Tucker and
Carl, especially if they potentially don’t
remember much of what took place in 2010.
Her death would be significant, because assuming
Josh and Dalton lost their memories, that
would leave Renai as the only one who truly
remembers everything that went on in 2010,
and she’ll be dealing with the difficult
quandary of whether or not to remind them
of those painful memories.
– [Renai] There’s so much you don’t know.
And I was too scared to tell you the truth.
– OK, so Dalton is going to college for art
school.
– You’re old now.
– No Dalton, you’re old now!
Interestingly in the trailer, he says he was
in a coma when he was 10.
In the script of Insidious, it suggests that
he was 8, but as we know the ages used in
scripts are not canon.
He looks more like he was 8 in the original,
and it would make sense if he was going to
college for the first time at 18.
But it could also make sense that he was 10, and
he started at a local community college for
the first two years, and now, 10 years later,
he’s 20 years old and transferring away
to university to study art.
Josh has some kind of artwork in his house
next to his pictures of Renai, which I’m
guessing is something that Dalton drew at
some point.
It’s fitting that he would become an artist,
because he loved to draw as a kid, in fact,
his drawings of what he saw in the Further
are what caused his parents to realize his
ability to astral project was real.
His art teacher talks about balancing light
and dark in his compositions.
And there’s a double meaning here, because
light and dark are terms sometimes used in
this franchise to describe the real world,
the light, and The Further, the dark.
And we see the beginnings of him drawing the
red door.
This suggests that it’s happening again.
Some of the pictures he drew as a kid were
pictures of the red doors that connect certain
areas in The Further.
The art teacher tells him to…
– sink deep into your memory and let’s
see what light can find.
– So I would surmise that his investigation
into this missing area of his memory causes
his astral projection ability to resurface
and cause The Red Face demon to have another
opportunity to possess Dalton’s body, just
as he had 10 years before.
In one shot we see Red Face reach out and
grab Dalton’s hand, leaving a big gash with
no blood, very similar to the injury that
Elise sustained in the 1980s when investigating
Josh’s paranormal issues with The Bride in
Black.
Speaking of whom, when I first saw the trailer,
I was confused because these are new photos
that we haven’t seen before.
We know The Bride in Black appears in the
background of photos taken of his target.
However, I believe these are just supposed
to be old photos of Josh that just weren’t
shown in the previous movies.
In Insidious 1, the photos are used to explain
to him what happened in his childhood, so
that’s probably what’s going on here again.
I don’t think The Bride is back.
It would be pretty disappointing if he came
back, because if that were the case, then
what was the point of the 2nd movie?
I do think that there are going to be new
photographs that feature a different lurking
entity however.
Dalton meets a girl at college and we see
them take a selfie together, but the trailer
doesn’t show the result of the photo.
However, we do see familiar things start to
happen, like a red handprint appearing on
Dalton’s bed.
While Dalton was in a coma in 2010, the family
discovered something similar on his bedsheet
before all hell broke loose.
We also see Red Face putting on his favorite
record by Tiny Tim, and what appears to be
Josh and Dalton approaching the red door and
entering Red Face’s lair.
In Insidious, as the ghosts around the house
started to smell Dalton’s empty vessel,
they got closer and started appearing more
frequently in the real world.
One of them sticks a hand out of a drawer
as Specs is closing it.
In the new trailer, we see something similar,
a hand protruding out of a wall.
Like the other films, there will probably
be an array of ghosts outside of the main
threat, some good, some neutral, some evil.
In this shot, Dalton discovers someone wrapped
in plastic, and if we bring up the lights,
there’s another creepy looking figure in
the distance.
There’s also a shot of someone aiming a
flashlight towards the demon, and you can
see another entity moving around in the background.
Watch your back.
We also see a new entity crawling out from
under a bed.
It looks kind of like this creature, who was
shot for Insidious The Last Key, but ultimately
never featured in the movie.
Closer to the end of the trailer, Dalton gets
dragged away with a chain on his foot, the
same way he was confined by Red Face in Insidious
1.
Additionally, there’s this part, where the
adult Dalton, Adulton if you will, sees the
scene from the end of Insidious Chapter 2
of his Dad, who is possessed at the time,
nearly about to strike him down with the hammer.
Remember, one of the traits of The Further
is it is not tied to time in the same way
that our world is.
It can show you different events from different
points in time.
Since Dalton doesn’t remember the events
of Insidious Chapter 2, he probably thinks
this is real.
We also see one of his paintings is a man
with a hammer standing in front of a red door,
maybe a result of his foggy memories of the
2nd film.
We also see a return of the can phone.
In Insidious 2, this was how Dalton and Foster
communicated when they were supposed to be
in bed, but it was later compromised by the
ghosts in the Further, trying to communicate
with Dalton.
He also used it to his advantage at the end,
as a way to find his way out of the Further
after locating his dad.
As for Elise, it seems she’s getting the
old Randy Meeks treatment this time around.
After her death in the first Insidious, she
helped out as a ghost in Insidious Chapter
2, claiming that she moved on to see a better
place, which is implied to be the equivalent
of heaven, but came back when she realized
the Lambert family was still in trouble.
– I’ve seen that better place, but I came
back here because I heard you calling and I think I can help.
– Chapter 2 ends with her as a ghost, joining
Specs and Tucker on their investigations,
although it appears that only little kids
can see her.
But after 10 years, you have to figure she
would have moved on to that better place,
permanently, because there is no joy in staying
in The Further.
Plus, she would probably want to be on and
be with her husband again.
It’s not clear if a ghost can come back
to the Further after entering the better place
beyond the Further.
At the end of the trailer we see the Insidious:
The Red Door logo.
This is actually something I’ve been waiting
for too, because I’ve spent probably too much
time thinking about the Insidious logos.
Starting with the second movie, the letters
SI are colored red, and I was always curious
if there was some meaning there.
In the third one the three I’s are red,
which seems to make sense.
It’s the third chapter and three Is represent
the roman numeral three.
Then The Last Key logo actually looks different in the trailer than it does on the poster, which made me question if there is any pattern to this
at all.
So the new logo has the SI colored red once
again, which I think may be an intentional
call back to the second film.
This is the true follow up to the Lambert
family story that we’ve been waiting for,
so it’s logo will follow that of the second
movie.
If that’s the case, it’s a lot simpler
than I thought it was going to be, for a while
I thought there was going to be some secret
message there, but I think that’s all it is.
But before the new Insidious comes out this
July, you need to get fully caught up on your
Insidious lore, so check out that playlist
on the left.
I’ve got a ton of Insidious content planned
before then, so make sure you don’t miss
out on that by subscribing to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ringing the deathbell
for all notifications and I’ll see you in
the next one.
Assuming we both survive.